finally joe biden concludes with his
statement he is going to stand at the
door of democracy and block it from the
dagger that's there
you're going to have to pry this
democracy for my gold lifeless
[Music]
here's joe biden
believe me
no i know how difficult democracy is i
don't believe you
i'm crystal clear
about the threats
that america faces
but i also know that our darkest days
can lead to light and hope
from the death and destruction as the
vice president referenced in pearl
harbor
can the triumph over the forces of
fascism
from the brutality of bloody sunday
on the edmond pettis bridge
became historic voting rights
legislation
so now let's step up
write the next chapter in american
history
where january 6 marks not the end of
democracy
but the beginning of a renaissance of
liberty and fair play
i did not seek this fight
brought to this capital one year ago
today
but i will not shrink from it either
i will stand in this breach
i will defend this nation
not allow no one to place a dagger at
the throat of democracy
um okay so he's really comparing january
6 to the edmund pettus bridge you mean
you know like a protest that the literal
authorities
sicked dogs on people who were
protesting a century of jim crow
that's the same thing as january 6th or
comparing it to pearl harbor because
it's just like pearl harbor when 2 300
americans died
or alternatively you just want what you
want and this is your excuse my favorite
part of this is that joe biden was asked
after his ridiculous speech about why he
had not used donald trump's name right
he kept avoiding trump's name he kept
saying the former president this and the
former president that his answer is just
it's one for the ages here was joe
biden's answer to that question
it's not about whether i'm president or
she's vice president
it's about the system and about somebody
who decides to put
himself above everything
and uh so
but i did not want to turn it into
a contemporary
political battle
between me and the president it's way
beyond that he didn't want to turn it
into a contemporary political battle
really that that is literally the only
thing that they are doing yesterday
that's the whole point of the exercise
is to turn it into a contemporary
political battle that's why you do a
memorial for january 6th that's why you
do all these commemorative editions cnn
specials and all of this kind of stuff
that's why you do it the whole point of
it is this you know what the real point
of this is the real point is that
non-farm job estimates came in 200 000
jobs below what they were supposed to
this month that's the real story
okay the actual democratic the december
jobs report came in adding 199 000 jobs
against expectations of 422 thousand
jobs that's the real story under joe
biden not that he's standing preventing
the dagger from entering the throat of
democracy or some such self-serving bull
bleep
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content